hi kevin o'leary or investor large in
Geneva where I've just come back from a
shopping trip and learned a very
important lesson you know I love her
maze fantastic ties what I hate about
them is the price so I like to shop for
volume see if I can get a discount I
went to the store in Geneva and I tell
you I like to buy those radioactive
bright ties you know the ones that you
need a battery just to keep them lit up
because they look great on television
I'll tell you I think these things are
the best in the world look at this one
for example how often can you get the
purple tie it's radioactive hmm just
love it that's her maze but wait there's
more I like to shop for a lot when they
get her maze rainbow of colors and this
year's design little HS is just perfect
so I go up to the counter and I say to
the lady I bought five how about a
discount you know I'm a bit of a
Phoenician it's sport to me I don't mind
spending two hours getting a five
percent discount and she looks at me and
she says why you buy somebody dies if
you can't afford them I thought she was
insulting me I said well no no I want
you to step up and buy a lot of ties
from you even though they're outrageous
Lee expensive but I'd like a twelve
percent discount knowing that settle for
five so she says to me but why don't you
wait till next month's paycheck and then
you can buy another time and I said no
no no no a discount I want a discount I
couldn't believe it no discount I was
there for about 30 minutes there was no
way she was going to give me one too
important lessons here I think from an
investment point of view number one
brand I wanted those her maze ties I end
up paying full price for them and it
killed me I wept like a child on the way
home broken but secondly think about the
last couple of years Thanks Giving
mortgages to people if they have the
same attitude and said why are you
buying a house you can't afford we
wouldn't be in this mess wearing today
sometimes there are things you can't own
because you can't afford them and that's
okay just a thought from your investor
at large kevin o'leary until next time